we begin with breaking news out of
Ukraine in one of the deadliest attacks
since Russia invaded Ukraine last spring
at least 51 people have been killed in a
strike on the herosa village in the
Northeast near Hakeem President Vladimir
zielinski says Russian forces shelled a
shop and a cafe in the village the
strike comes as zielinsky is in Spain
for a European security Summit
okay well let's bring in our
correspondent Zone Bess Ravi who joins
us from zapparisha in Ukraine and I know
it's early uh just an hour or so since
the attack can you just tell us what
more we know at this stage
well this attack happened at around one
o'clock local time it's been about five
six hours since this attack happened and
debris is still being cleared from the
site of this attack now it is about five
or six hours drive north of our position
in the kharkiv region in cupion's
District in a village called guroza and
what we know is that a cafe and Shop in
the middle of the day a daylight attack
was hit when people had gathered there
we are learning in the last hour or so
that the death toll has climbed people
who were wounded receiving Emergency
Medical Aid at the site of this attack
have died in the last few hours that
death toll is now at 51 killed we know
for a certain that at least one child a
young six-year-old boy was among the
dead as well what we also are hearing
this again one of the worst attacks in
recent memory we haven't seen anything
this big in a few months it was an
Ascender a Russian guided missile this
is a missile that can be aimed these are
meant to be very precise missiles they
carry they can carry up to a 700
kilogram Warhead so a very very large
missile used on seemingly
indiscriminately a civilian Target from
what we understand of that Village there
were no military assets nearby so why
this attack happened it still is unclear
if the Russians knew it was a civilian
Target or not but what people here keep
telling us is that in their experience
this could be a village anywhere along
the front line anywhere in the east of
the country going from the north to the
South this kind of thing continues to
happen in civilian areas we've seen many
towns here in zapparesia as well where
people say the same thing they feel that
they are in civilian spaces and this
kind of indiscriminate targeting is
continuing to happen it has been
happening since the War Began insane
what's been the reaction from cave
well president volada mirzolinski who is
in Spain at the moment for the EU
Council Summit he did come out very
strongly calling this an act of
terrorism saying that this kind of evil
needed to be stopped and anyone
supporting Russia was supporting uh in
his words evil terrorism being carried
out in his country a senior member of
his office the deputy head of the
president's office Alexi koleba came out
saying offering on social media
condolences for the dead offering his
well wishes but also saying it was now
time to take revenge for everyone that's
been killed in this war so very very
strong statements coming out from the
leadership in Kiev and it will be
certainly something that they point to
when they go to their allies and say
what they need now are better air
defense system more modern Weaponry to
be able to take back the Skies over
their country and bring this war to a
quicker end okay thank you so much for
that update that is best Ravi for us in
zapparesia
Maria avdiva is the research director at
the European expert Association in
Ukraine she joins us live from Keith
thank you very much for being on this
NewsHour as we heard from Zayn our
correspondent just there it doesn't seem
to appear to be any military
infrastructure in the area where this
strike happened I mean what do you think
it was targeted for
so this is a very tiny village where
about 300 people were living and 51 of
those locals were killed just in one
place they were gathering in the local
uh Coffee Shop grocery store like
Community Center in the center of that
Village and they were gathering there
for funeral so Russia hid exactly at the
time when uh like every six person from
the village was in that one place now
what is the reason is still a known
police and local Security Services are
on an investigation right now and
they're also asking locals because there
is assumptions that probably someone
give out the information or navigated
the strike because it was so precise and
hit precisely this sport where all these
people were but from what we see is that
Russia is all the time taken in the
direction of skin hercu region this is
one of the many attacks that happened
recently and just about two weeks ago
Russia attacked the bridge in coupons
where they were when they evacuation
Convoy was crossing the river and six
people who were being evacuated were
killed at that time
it sounds like this could have been an
ascanda missile uh which is really
precise it can be guided into a Target
do you think that this was a deliberate
attack on civilians
yes absolutely so this was clearly a
deliberate attack Russians knew that all
those people were there and they
precisely attacked this building how
their strike was so huge that from what
we know now only 30 bodies are being
able to be identified from 51 people
killed so means that 20 bodies us are
being still unidentified and the DNA
test will continue on the scene of the
attack and from what we know uh from
last Russians attacks of the same kind
which were on Pizzeria in chromators and
others then later police said that they
found people who navigated the strikes
those who gave out information and told
Russians when and where to heat I mean
this comes as zelinski is in Spain
trying to convince European leaders to
continue their support for Ukraine do
you think that this attack you know with
so many civilians dared here will
actually help him to be able to do that
well uh I The Hope here is that the
Western counties will continue support
for Ukraine because Russia is clearly
using this time not to stop the time
what it has but to continue its attacks
and they are becoming more and more
cruel so that's why Ukraine is asking
for this help and this help has to be
continued otherwise the number of uh of
people killed by Russia will only rise
imagine if Ukraine had enough
capabilities and enough uh weapons to
push Russians further from upans then
Russia won't be able to hit this
particular village with iskandar missile
so these are all
things that are very connected the more
weapons Ukraine will get the more
Ukrainian troops will be able to push
Russians out of the territory of Ukraine
okay thank you so much for your time we
really do appreciate it here on Al
Jazeera that is Maria of Diva the
research director at the European expert
Association in Ukraine thanks so much